les ong sont devenus 50 ans des acteurs
incontournables de la société moderne
par leur impact auprès des gouvernements
et du public confondant régulièrement
les grands principes avec leurs
objectifs politiques
ce sont des organisations non
gouvernementales mais pas des
organisations non politiques les ong
développent des stratégies d' influence
qui privilégie l'émotionnel sur le
rationnel le sectarisme de la majorité
d'entre elles des amène à des
interprétations qui exclut toute pensée
ou comportements n'allant pas dans leur
sens et leur condition n'hésitant pas à
tordre les faits et à utiliser tous les
moyens pour imposer leur vérité
[Musique]
une réunion jugée cruciale pour l'avenir
de l'humanité coup d'envoi de la coop
26,1 glasgow première conférence climat
de l'onu d'envergure depuis l'accord de
paris il ya six ans pendant deux
semaines les états vont se pencher sur
les moyens de réduire davantage les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
décisif selon les scientifiques pour
éviter un réchauffement catastrophique
de la planète
[Musique]
était avec un accord en demi teinte que
le g20 rives en écosse les dirigeants
des 20 plus grandes puissances du monde
vise comme objectif de limiter le
réchauffement à 1,5 degré avec les airs
un engagement aussi à ne plus
subventionner les centrales au charbon à
l'étranger mais pas de date claire pour
sortir complètement des énergies
fossiles ni pour arriver à la neutralité
carbone décevant juge le chef des
données
[Musique]
la coalition au pouvoir au japon devrait
conserver sa majorité parlementaire tout
en en perdant plusieurs dizaines de
sièges au parlement
élections législatives ce dimanche et
première estimation de médias locaux
après la fermeture des bureaux de vote
en avertissement pour le premier
ministre influent mieux qu'ici des
clichés date il reconnaît un repli de sa
formation
[Musique]
m
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france
est les travaux commencent se demande
qui dureront deux semaines la coop 26 et
donc lancé conférence de l'onu sur le
climat qui permettra de suivre
l'avancement des promesses prises il ya
six ans dans le cadre de l'accord de
paris quelque 200 pays s'étaient alors
engagés à réduire leurs émissions de gaz
à effet de serre en faisant moins appel
notamment aux énergies fossiles cette
nouvelle coop doit transformer ses
promesses d'ici à 2030 pour atteindre
ensuite la neutralité carbone autour de
2050 une conférence présentée par son
président comme celle de la dernière
chance en l'écoutent
hitchcock oui mes amis dans chacun de
nos pays nous constatons l'impact
dévastateur du changement climatique 5
inondations cyclones incendies de forêt
températures records et nous savons que
notre planète commune est en train de
changer pour le pire et nous ne pouvons
y faire face qu ensemble par le biais de
ce système international en tout cas
d'afflux faith in china consiste à
l'évolution rapide du climat est un
signal d'alarmé qui incite le monde a
intensifié l'adaptation à s'attaquer aux
pertes et aux dommages et à agir dès
maintenant pour maintenir l'objectif 1,5
en vie et nous savons que cette coop la
coop 26 et notre dernier espoir de se
maintenir 1,5 à portée de main
et c'est avec des engagements qui
déçoivent que les dirigeants des 20 plus
grandes puissances vont désormais
rejoindre un glasgow après deux jours de
sommet à rome
le g20 qui représente à lui seul 80% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre sa
déclaration finale était donc très
attendue concernant le climat notre
envoyé spécial a ramené cet élevage
c'est un accord de paris quelque peu
réchauffées qui ressort de ce g20
italien sur le front du climat les
dirigeants sont tombés d'accord pour
contenir la hausse des températures sous
la barre des deux degrés tout en
engageant des efforts supplémentaires
pour la limiter à 1,5 degré un objectif
qui nécessite des actions et des
engagements est significatif de la part
de tous les pays ont jugé les dirigeants
un accord qui va donc légèrement plus
loin que l'accord de paris de 2015 toute
la question va maintenant être de savoir
comment quel moyen elle les pays vont
engager pour atteindre cet objectif les
dirigeants ne sont pas parvenus en
revanche à donner à des dates est clair
pour sortir du charbon ou encore pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone du côté
des réactions elles sont en demi-teinte
à l'image de celle de mario draghi
l'hôte de ce sommet elle s'est tout de
même dit fier des résultats obtenus lors
de ce g20 mais il a temporisé ce n'est
qu'un début emmanuel macron a de son
côté estimé qu'il fallait obtenir
d'autres efforts de pays comme la chine
ou encore la russie pour autant ce g20
at il dit il a permis de recréer de la
convergence en vue de glasgow car c'est
désormais sur la coop 26 que tous les
regards vont être à braquer une échéance
cruciale donc sur le front du climat
boris johnson à d'ailleurs averti et si
glasgow échoue tout échoue et c'est donc
avec les mains pas tout à fait vite que
les chefs d'état vont s'envoler vers
l'ecosse pour la coop 26 mai les ong de
défense de l'environnement elles sont
déçues elles ont notamment dénoncé le
manque d'ambition et de vision de ce
communiqué final avec des demi-mesures
plutôt que des actes concrets même
constat pour antonio guterres est ce le
chef le secrétaire général de l'onu qui
a dit quitter ce g20 italien avec des
espoirs déçus
et en marge du g20 cette revanche cette
rencontre scruté de près entre à
emmanuel macron et boris johnson les
deux hommes ont échangé à la mi-journée
sur la délicate question de la pêche
post briques site
objectif briser la glace après des
semaines de tensions la france reproche
au royaume-uni d'accorder trop peu
licence à ses pêcheurs et se dit prête à
interdire dès mardi au bateau
britannique de débarquer dans ces ports
si londres ne répond pas favorablement à
sa proposition de désescalade le premier
ministre britannique lui reste ferme la
situation est donc toujours électrique
les deux hommes se sont exprimés au même
moment chacun de leur côté toutes à
l'arrêt côté
nous avons pendant quatre ans discuter
d'un accord accord de retrait puis
accord sur les relations futures dix
mois après la discussion de cet accord
plusieurs points ne sont toujours pas
appliqués du fait de la partie
britannique nous ne pouvons pas ne rien
dire qu'on parle de la vie de femmes et
d'hommes qui dépendent de leur travail
qui passe des jours et des nuits en mer
pour pouvoir nourrir leurs familles et
d'un seul coup parce qu'on ne respecte
pas un accord rendez-vous vous pouvez
plus vivre vous pouvez plus vivre de
votre travail c'est terminé mon souhait
c'est pas qu'on aille vers des mesures
de rétorsion parce que ça n'apporte rien
aux pêcheurs maintenant la balle est
dans leur camp si les britanniques ne
font aucun mouvement de manière évidente
les mesures qui sont prévues à partir du
2 novembre devront se mettre en place
parce que ce sera une fin de non
recevoir la balle est dans le camp des
britanniques en fiche à dans lequel il
en ce qui concerne la pêche je vais vous
répondre que notre position est
inchangée
or just say never je dirai juste pour en
faire un compte rendu
de lire une lettre du premier ministre
français où il dit explicitement que la
grande bretagne doit être puni pour
avoir quitté l'union européenne
et je ne pense pas que cela soit
compatible avec l'esprit de l'accord de
retrait signée avec nos partenaires
économiques
il est sujet de 10 quand multiplient
entre londres et paris renforcé par la
crise les sous-marins selon gilles
casanova expert en stratégie et
communication
il ya un grand c by day il ya un plus
petit c'est johnson donc il faut taper
sur johnson parce que bill donne n'est
trop fort donc on prend des positions
très fermes et très dure vis-à-vis de
johnson puis on se rend compte que c'est
un peu compliqué il faut avoir en tête
que boris johnson
il a un pays qui a entendu avec une
certaine émotion les propos du président
français il y a un an ou deux dix ans
qu'il ferait en sorte que le bras exit
ruine le royaume uni ils n'ont pas
oublié cela donc
boris johnson n'a pas le même caractère
évangélistes que emmanuel macron et donc
n'a pas envie de tendre l'autre joue et
rome marque la fin du conflit commercial
entre les états unis aient lieu sur
l'acier et l'aluminium crise déclenchée
par donald trump en 2018 joe biden et la
présidente de la commission européenne
viennent de conclure un accord le début
d'une nouvelle ère selon explications
adrien fantôme
c'était une volonté de joe biden c'est
désormais une réalité en italie pour le
dernier jour du g20 le président
américain a célébré des avancées
importantes dans les relations
internationales sur le plan économique
d'abord après des désaccords de longue
date sous le mandat de son prédécesseur
donald trump
ensemble les états unis l'union
européenne inaugure une nouvelle ère de
coopération transatlantique qui va
bénéficier à tous nos peuples
aujourd'hui et je le crois dans les
années à venir c'est un témoignage de la
puissance de notre partenariat solide et
de ce que les états unis peuvent
accomplir en travaillant ensemble avec
nos amis cet accord prévoit de supprimer
immédiatement les tarifs de l'union
européenne sur une gamme de produits
américains et réduit les coûts pour les
consommateurs américains
parmi les premiers produits concernés
l'acier l'aluminium exporté dans des
quantités défini et sans droit de douane
de l'europe vers les états unis des
échanges économiques renouer pour mieux
lutter face à la politique de la chine
et son acier produits à bas coûts
je suis très heureuse d'annoncer que
monsieur le président vous et moi avons
convenu aujourd'hui de commencer les
travaux sur un nouvel accord mondial sur
l'acier durable cela marque une étape
importante dans le partenariat renouvelé
entre l'union européenne et les etats
unis et c'est une première mondiale dans
nos efforts pour parvenir à la
décarbonisation de la production et du
commerce mondial de l'acier
le changement climatique inclus dans ce
nouveau partenariat joe biden est
maintenant tournée vers des enjeux plus
diplomatique entre les discussions avec
la france l'allemagne ou encore le
royaume-uni le président américain veut
renouer la confiance avec ses alliés
les japonais voter ce dimanche aux
élections législatives organisées par le
nouveau premier ministre du parti
libéral démocrate après avoir dissous la
chambre basse du parlement il espère
conserver une majorité de sièges est
resté à la tête du gouvernement mais la
popularité de son parti est en baisse
précision d'amaya se monnaient
[Applaudissements]
le parti de fouilles au kishida dans la
tente des résultats maintient sa
majorité parlementaire selon les médias
nippons mais perdre et malgré tout
plusieurs sièges à la chambre des
représentants quelque 106 millions
d'électeurs étaient appelés aux urnes ce
dimanche pour départager 1051 candidats
la population japonaise et lisez les 4
165 députés qui formeront la nouvelle
chambre des représentants des élections
organisées par le nouveau premier
ministre fumio qui cherche ignoré dans
un contexte politique et sanitaire
fragile kim est en déclin la popularité
du parti libéral démocrate
pour être honnête même si le dirigeant
du japon change je ne pense pas que cela
fera une grande différence au japon
comme cela a été le cas aux états unis
ce n'est pas un système où le peuple
peut choisir ses dirigeants coup
[Musique]
franc
très lointain nouvelle gare de
nantes a mis la panique je parle des
politiques avec mes amis et nous
finissons souvent par parler du fait que
nous n'avons pas un avenir brillant
cependant peu de mes amis vont voter
alors je pense que ce serait mieux si
chacun d'entre eux se rendent et aux
urnes afin de rendre l'âme n'est plus
brillants et les plus prometteurs
comme un pape avec
la foule
yoshida président du parti libéral
démocrate depuis fin septembre derniers
misent sur ces élections pour conserver
la majorité parlementaire qu'à obtenir
shinzo abe lors des dernières élections
de 2017
mais l'ancien premier ministre a été
contraint de démissionner à cause d'une
santé fragile pour laisser la place à
yoshi des sugar
suite à un record d'impopularité est
accusé d'avoir mal géré la pandémie
fumio kishida lui a succédé au bout d'un
an
le nouveau premier ministre axé sa
campagne autour de la lutte contre le
coc u19 et souhaite relever l'économie
du pays tout en réduisant les inégalités
sociales il devrait obtenir la majorité
la plus faible de ces dernières années
tout en conservant son alliance avec le
parti de centre-droit comme eto'o face à
eux l'opposition se fait de plus en plus
virulentes puisque cinq parties se sont
alliés qui pourrait affaiblir encore
plus la gouvernance de fumio kishida
à l'iran victime d'une cyber attaque
c'était mardi dernier qu'elle perturbe
depuis cinq jours le système de
distribution de carburant dans le pays
un haut responsable iranien évoque
aujourd'hui l'implication probable des
états unis et d'israël lire aux victimes
ces dernières années de plusieurs cyber
attaques sur des centrifugeuses ou des
ports maritimes
à mon avis la cyberattaque contre les
stations d'essence a été faite par le
régime sionistes et les américains nous
avons analysé deux incidents l'un l
attaque du port de chahid rajhi et
l'autre l incident ferroviaire de
juillet dernier il était similaire dans
le modèle d' attaque ils sont
définitivement nos ennemis c'est à dire
les américains et le régime sioniste
c'est une première aux états unis 100
détenus de guantanamo a publiquement
raconter les actes de tortures qu'il a
subis pendant plus de trois ans dans
cette prison militaire américaine située
dans le sud-est de cuba un témoignage
corroboré par une enquête du sénat
américain sur l' usage de la torture par
la cia après les attentats du 11
septembre nadège abderrazak
simulation de noyade bain glacé
privation de sommeil alimentation par
voie rectale on est en pleine période
d'halloween mais ce n'est pas le
scénario d'un film d'horreur que je vous
décris c'est une variété de méthodes de
torture apparemment utilisée par la cia
pour obtenir à des informations de
détenus de la prison de guantanamo c'est
le cas d'un ancien messager d'al qaïda
un pakistanais de 41 ans qui a émigré
avec sa famille aux etats unis ils la
racontent aujourd'hui les sévices qu'il
a subis depuis sa capture en 2003 il dit
avoir été suspendu par des chaînes
pendant plusieurs jours d'affilée nues
et sans rien à manger dans une cellule
sans fenêtre il décrit aussi à des
interrogatoires violents le visage
cagoulé plonger dans des bandeaux glace
et la tête maintenue sous l'eau jusqu'à
ce qu'il parle il me frappait jusqu'à ce
que je les supplie d'arrêter le pire
c'était de ne pas savoir quand les coûts
allaient venir ni d'où ils partiraient
ses interrogateurs ne se serait pas
arrêté là il aurait aussi menacé de s'en
prendre à sa famille et de violer sa
soeur il aurait aussi subi des lavements
forcée entre deux interrogatoires et
aurait été nourri de force par une sonde
anale lorsqu'ils étaient en grève de la
fin j'ai été violée par des médecins de
la cia alors que j'ai été ligotés ils
ont introduit des tubes et des objets
dans mon anus majid khan avait été
recruté par des membres de sa famille
appartenant à al qaïda pendant une
visite au pakistan il est passé aux
aveux quelques jours après sa capture le
5 mars 2003 à karachi il a reconnu avoir
participé à une tentative d'assassinât
du président pakistanais et avoir remis
50 mille dollars à des membres d'al
qaïda en indonésie une somme qui aurait
contribué à financer un attentat contre
un hôtel il vient d'être condamnée à 26
ans de détention par un tribunal
militaire américain et compte tenu d'un
accord passé avec le juge lorsqu'il a
plaidé coupable il pourrait être libéré
l'an prochain chaque fois que j'étais
torturée je leur disais ce que je
pensais qu'il voulait entendre je
mentais pour que les violences
s'arrêtent mais plus coopéraient plus je
parlait plus j'étais torturée cela fait
près de vingt ans que je suis détenu est
maintenue en isolement j'ai payé cher je
rejette al qaïda je rejette le
terrorisme malgré la gravité des actes
dont il a été jugé coupable
majid khan ne méritait pas un tel
traitement selon son avocate ni lui ni
aucun autre les mots forts de madjid
révèle les atrocités dévastatrice
commises par notre propre gouvernement
au nom de notre sécurité nationale le
programme de la cia a été un échec il
était contraire à nos principes
démocratiques et à l'état de droit c'est
sûr qu'on attend mieux d'une démocratie
supposé montrer l'exemple en tout cas la
condamnation est la même du côté des
nations unies en décidant de ne pas
engager de procédure contre les crimes
perpétrés durant les interrogatoires de
la cia les etats unis sont en claire
violation de la convention contre la
torture et envoie un dangereux message
de complaisance et d'impunité aux
officiels des états unis est au tour du
monde guantanamo fois un univers
carcéral de l'horreur créé sur une base
américaine à cuba par george w bush
après les attentats du 11 septembre 2001
aujourd'hui 39 détenus fille sont
incarcérés sur un total de 780 à y avoir
déjà séjourné
la plupart d'entre eux sont incarcérés
pour une durée indéterminée en l'absence
d'un quelconque procès équitable empêché
par le congrès barack obama n'a jamais
réussi chez à tenir sa promesse de
fermer guantanamo et ce n'était pas dans
les plans de son successeur donald run
bien au contraire la torture fonctionne
et si elle ne fonctionne pas il la
mérite pour ceux qui nous ont fait alors
qu'en sera-t-il de joe biden en 2009
lors de la conférence de munich sur la
sécurité
il est alors vice président il confirme
la promesse de barack obama de fermer
cette prison nous respecterons les
droits de ceux que nous traduisons en
justice et nous fermerons le centre de
détention de guantanamo bay les traités
et les organisations internationales que
nous construisons une doivent être
crédibles et ils doivent être efficaces
douze ans plus tard joe biden et
président des états unis mais la donne a
peut être changé notamment après la
fuite de kaboul et le départ mal négocié
des troupes américaines d'afghanistan
dans un tel contexte une fermeture du
centre pénitentiaire pourrait être perçu
comme un acte de faiblesse et pour cause
d'anciens détenus de guantanamo parade
aujourd'hui avec le nouveau gouvernement
taliban on pense notamment abdul qayoum
jacky vice ministre afghan de la défense
il y a été incarcéré de 2001 à 2007
en thaïlande photos liées et vendeurs
ambulants se préparent au retour des
voyageurs dès demain les touristes
vacciner et pourront à nouveau entrés
dans le pays cela faisait un an et demi
que bangkok avait fermé ses frontières
aux visiteurs étrangers un verrouillage
dévastateur pour l'économie thaïlandaise
avec des pertes évaluées à plusieurs
dizaines de milliards de dollars et la
perte d'emplois aussi pour plus de 3
millions de personnes sur l'île de
phuket les commerçants retrouvent espoir
je ne peux pas prédire si la réouverture
sera un succès à 100% ou seulement à 50
60 % mais si le nombre de touristes
revient à au moins 40 50% c'est mieux
que rien
nous pouvons voir l'espoir nous pouvons
voir la lumière au bout du tunnel nous
espérons que les affaires reviendront à
la normale et que j'aurai de l'argent
pour prendre soin de ma femme angolaise
en europe ne pas être vaccinés contre le
coc vite devient compliqué certaines
mesures entrent en vigueur demain
d'autres sont déjà mises en place par
les gouvernements ou bien les
entreprises privées tour d'horizon en
images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
et notre rubrique à présent heurtée sur
le web sélection d'articles à retrouver
sur notre site internet arte france
pointe et v1 le professeur out est
attendue vendredi prochain entre à la
chambre disciplinaire de l'ordre des
médecins accusés et entorses au code de
déontologie concernant la promotion de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine il risque
jusqu'à la radiation il n'assistera pas
à son audience mais dénonçant un
harcèlement de la part du président du
conseil national de l'ordre des médecins
[Musique]
le militant franco béninois kémi séba
annonce avoir été expulsé du burkina
faso ce samedi alors qu'il devait
assister à une marche de protestation
outre la présence militaire française au
sahel il dit avoir été placé en garde à
vue pour pouvoir manger et sans avoir la
possibilité de voir un avocat les
raisons de son expression n'ont pas été
dévoilés pour le moment
[Musique]
elle ne mâche pas ses mots anne hidalgo
sur candidate socialiste dans la course
à la présidentielle attaque le prétendu
candidat eric zemmour la candidature de
zemmour c'est la candidature d'un
guignol at elle déclaré ce dimanche la
maire de paris qui déplore le climat de
haine instauré par le polémiste les
détails c'est sur notre site internet
arte arte france pro tv
cela fait vingt jours qu'ils sont en
grève de la faim dans l'église
saint-pierre de calèches en prêtre et
2008 on réclame la fin des expulsions
des migrants et des saisies d'affaires
pendant l'hiver dépêchés par le
gouvernement un médiateur a été envoyée
sur place reportage de caroline béhague
et sébastien à part
[Musique]
combien sont ils
ceux qui sont bons
sur l'autoroute des strips souvient dans
un bassin du port
procès
[Musique]
quelques notes jouées en hommage aux
migrants de calais mort en tentant de
rejoindre l'angleterre brise l'attitude
de l'église saint pierre
[Musique]
ceux qui sont morts
sur l'autoroute destructeur
trois personnes y vivent simplement
entouré de messages de soutien les
traits tirés et affaiblis ils sont
toujours là au 20e jour de leur grève de
la faim tant que leurs revendications ne
seront pas écouté elles seront pas
appliquées je m'arrêterai pas qu'en fait
je m'alimente très bas tant que
tant que les expulsions en tout cas
auront encore lui l'église ne désemplit
pas ya des personnes qui arrêtent tout
temps il ya reçoit des lettres reçois
des messages sociaux ça nous porte
toutes ces personnes en fait qui
viennent témoigner
alors ou alors leur soutien leur message
en fait c'est le combat qu'ont décidé de
mener anaïs ludovic et le père philippe
soutenus par plus de 150 associations
ils ont décidé de mettre un coup de
projecteur sur le cauchemar des migrants
et des réfugiés de calais leur campement
serait régulièrement détruits par les
autorités et lorsque par bateau ou
camions ils tentent de traverser la
manche ils risquent à chaque fois leur
vie
par le déclencheur de cette grève de la
faim c'est le décès
d'un jeune soudanais qui s'appelle ya
soeur et qui en tentant de traverser
pour aller en angleterre est tombée d'un
camion est décédé est en fait ceux des
16 c'est vraiment le déclencheur mais
autour de ce décès s'articule aussi une
augmentation de 2,2 de la violence
policière une augmentation du
harcèlement des associations et ça ça
dure à peu près depuis on va dire un
mois un mois et demi pour l'instant
j'attends plutôt des réponses pl voilà
une prise de position de la part du
gouvernement soit ils acceptent soit il
refuse les revendications du trio sont
simples la suspension des expulsions et
des démantèlements des camps de migrants
durant toute la trêve hivernale et la
mise en place de points de distribution
de produits de première nécessité
après un premier contact infructueux le
22 octobre un médiateur a rencontré les
trois grévistes pour initier le dialogue
est rouverte pour le père philippe leurs
demandes sont non négociables les
policiers se saisissent des tentes de
tout ce qui est là et donc
même si le gouvernement un texte qu'il
est possible ensuite à la ressource sûrs
et de récupérer leurs affaires c'est
pratiquement impossible surtout qu'il ya
une dégradation volontaire de tout de
tout les effets des personnes exilées
les tentes sont déchirés au cutter c'est
quelque chose de très simple lui dire
qu'il ressorte de l'humanité la plus
simple donc dans notre esprit il n'y a
pas matière à discussion c'est oui ou
c'est non
d'après le rapport annuel de
l'association humanrights observers près
de neuf expulsions sur dix en france
entre novembre 2019 et octobre 2020 ont
lieu à grande synthe et à calais
s à la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve à 21h pour
un nouveau journal à total
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
été formés de gens merveilleux et d'aidé
de jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez
pas comment votre fils est mort